before we begin this video I'd like to
give a shout out to the sponsors of this
video immortal Taoists you thought that
Issyk I was the only trend in town right
but also gaining steam is the Walshes
genre tales of Chinese martial art
fantasy with its East Asian world
martial arts and plot immortal Taoists
has a lot for anime fans from the most
casual to the deepest in anime health to
enjoy the game has a lot of
customization options so you can go
ahead and turn yourself into someone
straight out of Demon Slayer or d'Oro to
help you get started we'll also be
giving out a promotion code and you guys
can use it to claim some awesome rewards
in the game check the link in the
description to download the game there's
no time like the present so come and
join the fun now it's no secret that
spring 2020 used to be known as the
blockbuster season of sequels to kick
off the new decade everyone was
anticipating the next season - their
favorite shows that is until
circumstances took those sequels away
from us one by one by one even some of
those that have begun airing like food
wars we're not safe needless to say a
lot of people were disappointed however
life and to a certain extent the anime
industry finds away and from the ashes
of the seemingly desolate season a lot
of new stars got the big break to shine
so for today I'll take you through a
rundown of 10 of the best non-sequel
anime that were released during this
spring season also I'm not going to be
including shows that have been cut short
or that have a confirmed July release
date as of the time of writing so
basically there goes millionaire
detective
[Music]
to start things off at number 10 we take
a look at princess connect tree drive
bonus uber in 2020 looks pretty good now
don't you think I thought that it would
be a matter of time before princess
connect gets his anime adaptation given
the amount of money sigh games is
drowning it right now looking at the
results so far I think we've got a
pretty nice result don't you think
princess connect tree drives main appeal
in my opinion comes from the fact that
the series feels like it's going for the
easygoing chill and wholesome route
hence the connoisseur comparisons of
course we all know how gone a tsuba
ended up being one of the best comedies
I want to think that princess connect is
nowhere near that level I would say it
makes a nice alternative if you're in
for that kind of storytelling
the characters are bubbly and fun the
world looks great and the voice acting
is top-notch
each episode of princess connect is a
fun adventure in its own right and if
you find yourself having fun with the
antics of our main quartet you're
definitely gonna enjoy this ride
[Music]
being an artist in the Renaissance is
tough even more so if you happen to be a
woman who indulges herself in the
pursuit of arts social norms were a
painful women during those days and
doubly so for art day who loses her
father the only person who really
believes in her passion for art refusing
to just sit back and settle in as a
Nobles wife art day gets a big break as
The Apprentice of the master artisan Leo
with a new life ahead of her she must
earn her keep and rush head on the road
to becoming a master artist herself it
may not be the sheltered life of a noble
that she would have had but it's one
that she would take in a heartbeat
our day provides a feminist take on
what's known as a male-dominated field
in the Renaissance era it has a relaxing
colorful setting complemented by a lead
that you can't help but cheer for the
series also cover some mature themes
that not a lot of people can see being
tackled in this medium sitting in our
8th spot is wave listen to me this is a
cautionary tale of recklessly spilling
your sorrows onto strangers thanks to
Minari ranting about her misery and
misfortune she finds herself a recipient
of unwanted exposure through the radio
to make matters worse her frustrated run
to the radio station ended up with her
suddenly becoming the next big thing on
radio as a late-night talk show host at
least things seem to be working out well
for menara who suddenly finds herself on
the road to her next venture in the
world of radio all while balancing her
new venture with the other aspects of
her personal life those who have gone
through menara situations would no doubt
have a blast with this series as
everyday antics end up hitting a bit too
close to home even if you don't the
comedy aspect of it still holds up quite
well I think this has got something to
do with the excellent voice acting which
for me is by far the best part of the
show and fittingly so as well given the
subject and premise
here's a sleeper hit that I didn't
manage to talk about preseason to sum up
the story in more easy terms
kikuchi godo is the story of Kakashi a
manga artist who makes a questionable
content and therefore vows to keep his
profession a secret from his daughter of
course this includes wild situations
like pretending to be a salaryman well
as you'd expect hijinks ensue as he goes
to all lengths in order to protect his
precious daughter from his not so
innocent job the show's highlighted by
all the silly and over-the-top attempts
by a main character in order to hide his
secret endless laughs are to be had in a
story about a dad trying to outsmart his
ever curious daughter I think the story
is a unique take on the father-daughter
sub-genre which is typically dominated
by wholesome relationships of growth in
Kakashi godo comedy takes the forefront
and the results are amazing at the
halfway point is my next life as a
villainous everyone can't stop talking
about but Carina what I thought was a
potential hit for the season ended up
delivering spectacularly capturing the
hearts of many anime fans this season
thanks to the brand-new twist in the
isso guides onra see this is exactly why
a Sakai is here to stay unlike the
previous three to five year trends like
the magic Academy harms of the early
2010's
to be fair my next life as a villainous
is a very entertaining show - the
novelty of it being an izakaya that's a
reverse harem and starring the supposed
villain for once the plot ended up being
quite wholesome as well with Katerina
trying to prevent bad endings by
becoming friends with everyone I think
the best part of the show is the
characters who all bring something new
to the table along with Katarina who for
me is one of the most entertaining yokai
leads in the modern era the cast is just
a good lineup of guys and gals that mesh
well together in the finished product
it's an anime that will bring smiles to
your faces and I personally anticipate
each new episode with eagerness it's
called fashion time if there was anime
this season that was the part of a lot
of jokes it was most definitely this one
and I had a good time laughing along
with those two but beyond all those
jokes and memes about Zootopia trigger
and furries BNA ended up a pretty good
anime in its own right you know it also
got all episodes released in a hurry so
that's a point for it for those who want
to bend something or
way to the end now one I'd say that
trigger is capable of doing more I think
in a vacuum BNA is a pretty damn good
show you know I think the last few
episodes are following that big reveal
could have helped push the show in a
good direction and it was unfortunate
that it had to be cut short given the
episode countersigned for this series
despite all of its wrinkles especially
in the last few episodes I had a lot of
fun following the story of this show if
you're up for a quick Adam a fix and
want to see what triggers up to now BNA
is your go-to show for this season you
know I didn't really know what to expect
from glide near before the season
started then I watched the first few
episodes got hooked and started reading
the manga and the rest is history
in my opinion the big appeal of glide
there is just how well it manages to
connect conflict after conflict perhaps
it's due to the unique dynamics between
the main duo or the surprisingly great
fight animations but the show never
ended up being a slog to watch it's
either that or after thoroughly enjoying
Darwin's game the previous season I'm up
for more edgy survival but for anime
among the action titles this season I
vouch for this one in terms of good old
dumb fun many people including me that
is have repeatedly questioned the weird
premise but I ended up enjoying the show
far more than I expected anyway beware
though the fanservice can get pretty
gratuitous midway through
for our next entry great pretenders got
you covered now I'd say with its run
being underway great pretend is shaping
up to be one of the more promising
up-and-coming titles out there starring
a duo of con men great pretender follows
their journey as they find their
swindling lifestyle backfiring on them
before the season I had some lofty
expectations for this show and I can
confidently say that the show does bring
a lot of crazy fun that you don't see
every day
so far it's gone on to make a promising
start with nice art some nifty color
palettes and a very comfy premise not to
mention the soundtrack that's just pure
fire great Pretender from what we've
already seen of it looks more and more
promising with each passing episode note
the studio wit went out of their way to
go for this project instead of attack on
Titan season 4 so that's got to mean
something in terms of how much stock
they're putting into it right it's been
a while since I've seen one of these but
seeing yesterday for me is actually
pretty good as a coming-of-age story I
admit that I overlooked this one when I
was doing my pre season previews thanks
to the sequels that we eventually ended
up getting robbed of mostly in a way I'd
say that having all of those delayed
sequels ended up being a blessing in
disguise of sorts because it allowed me
to chance upon this series you probably
won't know me as that big of a fan of
shows like this compared to the more
action II ones but this anime has caught
me and it's narrative I guess it has to
do with the relatable characters it's
mature take on romance or the
outstanding visual and production
quality that the show has to offer
whatever the reason is I would vouch for
this show definitely when it's all said
and done sing yesterday for me it could
very well end up being the underrated
title of this season
coming into the season I had high
expectations for Tower of God and what
do you know it really delivered didn't
it for me at least it was a no-brainer
putting this show on top of this list
am I being biased because I'm a big fan
of the source material maybe but it is
what it is isn't it I love it when the
hype for a show does deliver I had my
reservations due to the 13 episode
format and that the resulting pacing
issues but overall I'd say I'm pretty
satisfied I think that this show in the
season has the wide appeal game down pat
and with this blend of an interesting
world a gripping narrative and a large
cast of vibrant characters it comes up
with a good addition to the modern
library of epic fantasy I think that
this being given 13 episodes ended up
being the show's bane because having
read some of the original webcomic I'd
say that such a short run doesn't do it
justice especially in the world-building
aspect with that being said I think
Tower of God is the best original anime
this season has to offer simply because
of how it hits the right notes for such
a broad audience if you're enjoying the
first season let me tell you this you
haven't seen anything yet personally I
can't wait for more Tower of God as well
as more webtoon adaptations so what do
you think then a pretty good season when
it's all said and done isn't it there
are a lot of good shows that you're
missing out on if you're not watching
much anime this season this further
shows that even in times of adversity
the anime industry can keep going let's
all thank the guys behind these shows
and the creative minds behind it all for
giving us entertainment in our times of
need so what are you waiting for pick
your show from this list and start
catching up don't forget to check out
our sponsors Gabe immortal Taoists next
months their one-year anniversary and
I'm sure that most of the 2 million
people who've downloaded the game will
have something to say about it that's
not even getting to the 200,000 Facebook
fans and the 30,000 fans on the official
discord and if that's not enough to
convince you then maybe people on Google
Play can help you out after all
it's going to be on its recommendation
page and we'll be tying that momentous
occasion with an in-game event so check
the link in the description to download
the game for free also hit the like
button and subscribe for more anime
content and I'll see you next time
on Vinnie tube
[Music]
you
[Music]